[Music]
there yeah you you grew up almost on the
show how have these people become your
real-life family for guys like you have
to meet the parents which is stressful
but then I think the more stressful
thing is to like meet them like that's
the second family that is like I think
the most terrifying thing for guys that
I date have you introduced Wells to them
yet no I'm waiting we're waiting Wells
right here in the Dunfield living room
feel free to show up whenever you want
Julie you told us that you really liked
him he seems like a really nice guy and
he treats it really well and she's happy
as can be
she just showed me pictures and they and
the original sort of flirty texts that
were very sweet and there was no there
was nothing naked about them so I'm a
little I'm a little old-fashioned and I
liked that how did you guys meet it's a
long story
sarah hyland played coy about her new
beau Bachelorette alum Wells Adams when
et spoke with her on the modern family
set as the sitcom celebrates their 200th
episode milestone
I love how open and honest you are with
your fans why is that important for you
to be able to kind of have that
transparency I try to be the best role
model that I can be I feel like it's
very important for youth to have very
strong-minded opinionated young women
out there well you and Ari all do that
so well just a dumpy sister thing I
think so
[Music]